[Musique]
ce lundi 15 janvier ont été inaugurés
les nouveaux aménagements de la route
départementale 3 qui traverse le
quartier de piton des goyaves situé dans
les hauts de la commune de petite île ce
quartier ne disposait d'aucun
cheminement piéton sécurisé malgré un
trafic moyen journalier de 3000
véhicules
les travaux ont duré 11 mois de travaux
consistait à sécuriser les cheminements
piétons donc un trottoir a été créé tout
le long sur 1 kimi 400 m on a également
supprimé remplacer des ouvrages
hydrauliques qui permettent à des
ravines de passer des débits de plus
central des zones où on a créé du
stationnement et aussi des plateaux pour
faire ralentir la circulation des
véhicules motorisés
coût total de l'opération un million
cinq cent mille euros
une action menée avec le conseil
départemental qui a financé ces travaux
à hauteur de 900 mille euros une
opération importante
c'est aussi une façon pour nous de
façonner l'image d'un bourg et
aujourd'hui quand on traverse piton des
goyaves on a l'impression d'être
vraiment dans une petite ville et c'est
un petit peu l'objet qu'on souhaite
donner l'objectif qu'on souhaite donner
à l'ensemble des bourgs de notre commune
il s'agit aussi d'améliorer le cadre de
vie et le cadre de nos concitoyens qui
résident dans nos quartiers pour les
habitants du quartier de piton des
goyaves la réalisation de ces nombreux
aménagements à côté sont scellés
mais j'ai bien c'est pour la sécurité de
nos enfants sur les routes
pour nous aussi on avait besoin d'une
sécurisation
le maire a ensuite invité les habitants
à planter des arbustes le long de la
route puis partagé un pot de l'amitié
[Musique]